all right percy
yeah percy uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally um
i'm i'm from the bronx i've never moved
uh i
i'm kind of that's that's just my home
base i've been stationed there all my
life
um
you're 14 years old yep
uh i'm i'm just some kid
um i'm just a kid who has to be here and
now i'm here
so you know
tell me about your family uh my family
all right um
it's it's strange um because i
i was birthed um my brother was already
eight uh he's 22 now there's like
there's like a really big gap between us
and he wasn't really um didn't really
like you because it was so annoying but
um
and then there's me madre um my mom was
mostly the person who um who stepped in
to raise me my dad was and still is
really distant
um and that made that made it really
hard on her um
your dad's not in your life
my my dad is in my life but he also
isn't he's he's absent but only
emotionally he's here physically but
it's like
it's like he's not there
um
he's like he's just he's just upstairs a
lot of the time and
um
when we do see him he's just kind of in
the living room chilling there doing
absolutely nothing and you know i
respect the grind but can you help a
little bit
um
he lives with you and your mom yeah okay
uh
he lives with us and um
why do you think you're not as close
with your
dad uh i could tell very when your mom
walked in with you you were very close
with your mom i'm i'm really close with
my mom yeah um because as i was growing
up he kind of didn't know how to parent
in the slightest and it was just
it was just real strange
um
just all that time i
was was only seeing my mom um and when
my dad was here and he would try to do
stuff he it was always it was always
really strange it was always really
awkward um
because
he just wasn't there
um
and
he tended to like yell at me a lot
whenever i did
the anything
um
there were there were still some there
were still some good times i had with
him back when i was like
10 or so but also back when i was like
10 or so i realized damn
this is messed up um
i i vividly remember some things like
how
he
um
i was crying i was crying and i was
crying on the phone with my mom and um
my uh my dad were like yell at me stop
the crying stop the crying and i was and
me as like a tiny little baby kid was
like i don't know how he expects me to
stop crying when he's yelling at me and
i don't remember what my mom said
um
i
that part that part was just blocked out
of my mind but i'm i
i think she helped but i don't
um
what do you think the problem is with
you and your dad
he's just
he doesn't know
how to parent he doesn't know how to
properly socialize
with his family he doesn't know how to
build truly intimate relationships and
when anyone tries to like take him up on
that he just kind of shuts down and
but he's he comes from a different
generation yeah he comes from a
different generation and it might be
harder for his generation to accept
i i definitely understand that you're so
you're trans yep um i'm transgener but
my dad actually accept that and um he he
understands what it's like and i'm super
grateful for that however comma um the
way he acts just isn't it
know what i'm saying
um
i don't know if any of this is coming
out right i don't know if um
like it seems like i'm being hyperbolic
or blowing things out of proportion but
you're a teenager
i'm baby i'm i'm baby
huh what grade are you in uh about to be
in the ninth you're about to be a
freshman yeah
speaking of speaking of the ninth grade
i almost did not
get into high school in the first place
um
uh speaking of ninth grade i didn't i
almost didn't get into high school in
the first place uh
kelvin
kelvin that was really tough on me
because i was like what 12.
i was like i was like 12 in the middle
of like covet times and school just
suddenly
just left school was suddenly just gone
and i consider myself um a social person
i um
i basically i need other people around
me
you're forced to isolate
and yeah i was forced to isolate and i
the rest of the rest of that time
and it started from march the rest of
that time has just escaped me all i
remember
is like being in my bed 24 7 not doing
anything
because i couldn't do anything and even
when i could i
just didn't feel like it and that
extended all the way over to seventh
grade where i just
didn't
i i just i stopped trying online school
i never went
um
and i would i would just sit there and i
would how did it affect you emotionally
emotionally a lot you got depressed yep
very
um
what kind of emotions do you deal with
anger
anxiety or depression um
mostly depression i
i was i was really depressed i would
stare at my schoolwork i would stare at
my schedule and i just wouldn't i
couldn't bring myself to do anything
um
and
like at the at the end of the year
something funny about the end of the
year because uh
i was i was like damn all right uh
better look next time but
during the summer
it's still like smacking the face
because
i was alone there was there was nothing
there was nothing really for me to do
um
do you have friends
i i do have friends you have good
friends yeah that's great i have friends
it's important
i have friends um friends on the
interwebs friends in the real life but i
didn't really feel like i could talk to
them because i was just laying there and
they'd sleep yeah recovery just kind of
passed now yeah um
and i'm cool um
i would sleep so much that like at the
during the entirety of the day i would
be gone and all night i i would stay
awake and
that
basically spiraled down into me just
being entirely alone with my thoughts
not even not even like having um any any
friends to talk to during those times
not even um my mom because she was
asleep and i never wanted to wake her up
i still don't want to make her up um
and then i
i was i was forced to sit back and just
look
look at all of the things that happened
and i was like damn
i'm really sad and it kind it
spiraled down again i love spiraling um
i don't uh into into suicidal thoughts
and i
i remember this one particular night
when i was in so much distress because i
had i had realized
a lot of the things
that happened to me way back in the day
i can get into that that can that could
be a whole different conversation but um
i i realized like damn
that's not good that's
that
that's not good
why is that not good what kind of stuff
happened to you is it
uh all right
eight-year-old with unrestricted
internet access that is that is a train
way train whack train wreck
waiting to happen um
i
uh found i found this weird uh social
media thing uh
i don't know if i should name it but uh
it was like it was like really active
for
some
strange reason and there are a lot of
people there are a lot of people on
there um
and unfortunately i came across some bad
people there's glitter on me
i'm sorry um
so
thing about that
there were a lot of people who were
perfectly willing to take advantage of
me when i was like
a tiny little baby kid um
there were there were people who um who
grew me into being okay with sexual
things there were people who
were just straight up [ __ ] creepy
like stereotypical stranger danger [ __ ]
and i didn't
really
think a lot of it because like oh no
it's okay i have the i have the blog
button it's fine it's fine it's fine but
the thing about
grooming
is that
it it
it turns your mind into this it
it's this thing where it's like oh yeah
that's okay
that's that's that's fine i can i can
handle that on my own it's okay
except it's not
it never is
um
and
for the for the next couple years i was
like a really sexual person in quotes
because i was like [ __ ] 10. um
but you're
at 14 you've not had sex yet no
i mean
get into that later hold on a second uh
let's not get ahead of ourselves
and
it took me
until i was like 12
to realize that and i was like damn
what the [ __ ]
excuse my language but what the [ __ ]
um
i was i was also on like another website
where you can like livestream yourself
and there would be people who are
keeping an eye on you and there are
really creepy people on there i don't
know um
and
you know i i remember like seeing this
video that was like someone being like
oh um stop sending me dick pics lol xd
and making this into into this really
humorous thing it was an adult
i was putting that out there and i was
like oh yeah that's that's humor i i
this this this is this is wrong but it's
funny it's funny it's funny um
and then like i posted this video
because there was like a video sharing
feature uh because i was receiving those
i was receiving like sexually explicit
images and i was like oh yeah stop stop
sending me these because i'm i'm so
badass and i thought i was so cool
but
i was upstairs um in my dad's room
um
and like i was i was recording something
and my dad came up and he was like why
are you recording in my room this room
this room is a mess you shouldn't you
shouldn't be doing anything here and
like he um took my tablet because i
didn't have a phone thankfully um i had
a tablet i had this little thing uh
this was not durian this wasn't doing
grove attacks this was way back when uh
i have i have trouble like stringing
times together my bad but
uh my dad like took my tablet and looked
at the look looked at the [ __ ] that i
was posting it was like what the [ __ ]
but like in the worst way possible
um
and like he went down and told my mom
but my mom was like so much more casual
about it and she was like
hello
and she seemed genuinely concerned but
my my dad seemed angry my dad seemed so
angry at me um and i understand that i
understand that completely because you
know hard to find out that your child is
um
just this close to being sexually
exploited on the internet but that's not
the way you know um
and he ended up like
uh
smashing my mobile device in front of me
uh which again i understand
but that wasn't the way
um
and just
straight up took away all my [ __ ]
for like four months
uh
i
i just
lost all of my things i was away from uh
the friends that i actually made the
friends who
uh were my age and didn't
uh do anything do anything
uh suspicious
but i was like
completely disconnected i was in another
world
um
and
one day
i was like hey
can i get my [ __ ] back
it's
it's been a while can i please get
and my my dad really didn't say anything
about it at least that's what i remember
but my mom's like okay
here you go
don't don't do that [ __ ] again
um
and i didn't realize the gravity of it
until coveted times a circle circle on
back to over there um
and a little disclaimer i
sorry i get distracted so much but
little disgrace disclaimer i don't think
my dad is a bad person
i just
i just think he's been misled a lot and
he doesn't have the capability to change
right now i don't think he's going to
have the capability to change every
anytime soon but
it's fine
it's not fine but it's fine
do you have goals in your life and
things you'd like to do yeah uh
i got goals um i'm so sorry for getting
sidetracked if you have to cut all of
this out it's fine but
um
whose id whose idea was it to come on my
channel mine yours i did that
um and your mom said okay yeah my mom my
mom thought it was okay what would you
like to do when you grow up when i grow
up uh when i become a big big man
um
i actually don't know because um
my livelihood has changed a lot
um
what i want to do
because
um
[Music]
at first i didn't know because i was a
child i was like eight but then i wanted
to i wanted to be a doctor and i did a
bunch of research on doctor [ __ ]
um
and but then with my little child brain
um
i started
i started panicking i started panicking
because like
zam what if all of these things that
could happen to other people happened to
me
and
then i i started going absolutely insane
dog um
i would um i would like frantically wash
my hands until they became raw i would
like even if i sensed the slightest
thing that was off i would cry and try
desperately to fix it um and this was
all when i was a little baby um
and that just still affects me to this
day
uh
but
that's that's why i kind of turned away
from the doctor thing i still want to
be someone like that because you know
now that i'm older i can probably handle
it without freaking the [ __ ] out um
but you're still very young yeah i'm
still a baby you can change your mind 12
times i
i can i can change my mind as many times
as i want but and i know that but i
forgot sometimes
uh
i like to do art i like to draw and
there is not there's not really much
um
of
there's not really much of a future for
um artists
nowadays um but is that how you feel
uh yeah
but i still do like to draw i still do
like to like to do a lot of stuff
speaking of art i like to write there is
in fact a future for writers um there's
a future for artists too but uh yeah
just draw something and make make money
but um
still it's more complicated and you know
writing has like a greater opportunity a
greater chance of doing stuff maybe yeah
um
i have i have a lot of trouble finishing
things for example
the entire time in the talking you
haven't been able to finish something i
have a lot of trouble with that now
you're doing fine
however you can find do you find the
future
bleak or are you discouraged about what
possibilities are ahead of you because
of what's going on in the world because
of
everything from covid to
wars to
energy to you name it
yeah but i like to ignore that right now
because you know i'm i'm a kid sometimes
i forget that i'm a kid but
i'm going to compartmentalize
that stress
for
i mean i always have to worry about it
but
save it for later until like i'm what
16 or something
uh
i i really do
um
dream
of being able to being able to finish a
book and get it out there and
actually like have people read it and
have people
enjoy what i do because
um
not to not to my own war in hong kong
but um a lot of people seem to enjoy
what i do already um do you enjoy what
you do yeah that's important uh when i
like write something and i show it to
people people are damn
you're pretty cool and i'm like damn i
might be pretty cool you're only 14.
yeah
um
imagine how good you'll be when you're
16.
yeah
you seem super intelligent for a 14 year
old
a lot of a lot of people say that and
i'm like
um am i really uh
but
you know sometimes sometimes you gotta
believe what people tell you
and
you know uh since i since i shot my shot
and uh went on here
maybe i maybe i'm starting to believe
what people tell me yeah although it
takes a lot of confidence to come on my
channel
for a 14 year old to do it makes you
know it's really impressive
are you generally happy
uh are you a happy person or do you make
your life miserable
uh it's kind of like
schrodinger's mental state because
um
[Music]
usually most of the time i'm just i'm
just like this this bright individual
and i come off that way and i really
like coming off that way because it's
fun
um
it's it's really fun to
be
happy it's fun to do that but on the
other hand um
i don't like existing um
i don't like it it gets really hard i
[ __ ] up a lot
um
and
that's just being a teenager it's just
me
um
but you know being a teacher being a
teenager is hard and
uh
people who like dismiss someone's
struggles just because they're a
teenager isn't fair and i'm not talking
about you please i swear i'm just
talking about the general populace no
but like if i had a teenager like you as
intelligent smart together as you are
i'd be very proud
thank you
you're impressive
thank you so much um
that means a lot that really means a lot
when a lot of people say it
um
but
where was i
we're just talking about your future and
whether yeah um optimistic or
pessimistic about the future uh
i don't know i'm just like the glass is
the glass type person
uh glass has water in it
doesn't it doesn't matter if it's half
empty or half full
what do you see among your friends um
what kind of situations are they in are
there are there drugs in your life are
there friends oh no no no no thankfully
thankfully that hasn't happened uh no
romance yet
uh actually i have a boyfriend you do uh
i do um we have been together for two
and a half years
and that means so much to me since you
were 11. yeah
um that means so much to me i really i
um despite what a lot of people say oh
middle school relationships
um i do uh see a future with him
uh
really really nice
um
and i'm
[Music]
i'm i'm a simple person i'm shrimp um
and he's also shrimple uh i mean not not
actually simple because i'm i consider
myself a complex being with the with the
inner workings and stuff like that
however
um there's just
there's a lot of
hype around like being in a relationship
nowadays right
um
trailing off who cares at this point um
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna stop
caring whatever uh question answer
whatever but
there's like there's like this
this
requirement to like get into
relationships and uh and i don't i don't
get that i don't get that truly because
um people who are
really really
um
hyper to get into a relationship really
don't think about the future and i
waited till i was 26.
huh i waited until i was 26.
reasonable very very reasonable um
that was the smartest thing i ever did
yeah
um because you're just not i wasn't
mature enough
at 20 or at 18 or 17.
or 14 or 11
or 11 any of any of those times um
because a lot of people my age
yeah they just they just feel like it's
a requirement and kind of
sorry um
i know i don't mean to say them them
damn kids
but oh did you like school
you're back to school right you were
yeah yeah do you like school
are you looking forward to high school
i am actually um
i'm so sorry i keep trailing off uh
there's a lot of things that i want to
talk about there are a lot of things
floating around in my brain and
sometimes i just don't finish what i'm
saying which is fine um
school school is
um
because i i used to be i used to be one
of the gifted kids right gifted kid
disease that
i hate that um
[Music]
i used to get like straight as in all my
classes and whenever i didn't whenever i
got like an 80 i would cry
um but like fast forward into the now
now uh after covet happened and uh fun
fact i've also i've also been to a
psychiatric institution like three times
oops uh
tell you all about that later
compartmentalizing things i love that
word but uh
i just like i
and then i start and then i stop caring
and i hate that i stop caring i really
really hate that i stop caring and
i really hope that i can start caring
when i'm in high school but
um throughout the eighth grade fun fact
um
eighth grade was horrible uh you know
why because i was gone off the face of
the earth not even doing school for like
three months because i
um was sexually assaulted
uh
it was it was in broad daylight in uh
i'm not gonna talk to myself um
in the in the middle of the park where i
was trying to go onto the swings
the swing set and that just that just
[ __ ] me up big time because you know i
was i was already failing all my classes
and [ __ ] but then three months three
months just zipped by and i just didn't
[ __ ] do anything
um
i didn't even like get to
getting home instruction until
time
uh
until like january
um
and even then like not much happened and
then i went back to school and i didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going on
sorry for the language but i don't i
don't i did not know what was going on
and i was i was in the class with all
the the gifted kids um
and
i didn't know what was happening so i
kinda i kinda just sat there
um
i i tried i tried my best but in the end
like i ended up getting moved to another
classroom uh for like regular
curriculums because um
in my in my other class it's called
howard just call it howard doesn't it
doesn't really affect anything but in
howard they were um they were like
advanced lessons they were um regent's
level classes so like you could take um
a
like a regents test at the end of the
year and then you wouldn't have to take
it in high school but
gone
didn't know what's happening didn't
really care anymore so i got distracted
uh yeah and then i got smooved um are
you a good student
i would consider myself one yeah you
seem very bright
i would consider myself a good student
i'm just in really unfortunate
circumstances
um
and
hopefully when i get to high school
those circumstances
won't
get in the way anymore well your
circumstances aren't that horrible yeah
um you got a mom who loves you you
probably have a dad who loves you too
he's just my my dad my dad does love me
um and i know that he loves me he's just
really weird about it he's really really
weird about it you probably make it
difficult for him
you know
you guys have to understand each other
yeah um and i i hope to and see how you
both make it difficult for each other
yeah
um
i i really hope to i really hope to
rebuild that bridge i really hope to
repair that relationship one day but
i don't think he's ready for that right
now
um and there's a lot there's a lot more
about me father
um and
that that like i
i don't don't be a victim
huh don't be a victim
it's a bad it's a it's a terrible
attitude to take with you terrible
attitude to take with me
poor me poor me poor me
yep
really really poor attitude
and you seem to have a lot going for you
i do have a lot going on in every way
and just take that and run with it
i have a lot going for me but i
i have a lot of things that make it hard
but you know
it's only as hard to make it
how big a factor is being trans in your
life
actually not that actually not that big
times have changed
how times have changed uh because i live
in an area where you're not allowed to
be homophobic or else you will die
you'll not literally die but um
you're not allowed to do that because
people are people are really accepting
people are like cool
people are cool about that
um
and
just just in general people don't seem
to care
which is cool which is nice and i'm
really lucky to have that really lucky
to live in a place
where
people
don't care about who you are
you're very lucky
very very lucky um
i've taken i've taken the time to
like reflect on
stuff [ __ ] up a lot of stuff
um
and you know
trauma
trauma bad
but
you you good
i'm cool
i'm cool
and i don't
it doesn't have to shape me you know
um
i love rambling
rambling is my forte baby oh yeah what's
your favorite personality trait about
yourself
about myself
i
let me think because i i don't mean to
toot my own honk honk but i think there
are a lot of good things about me
um
i'd say
i'd say that i am really bright
i'd say that
i
am a person who has the capacity to know
a lot of things and you know that
stabbed me in the ass a couple times but
um
i
i have all that i have all that and
i
can and i will learn to
put all that on a shelf
and
use it because i i've been using it a
lot
i've been using a lot of the [ __ ] that
has come up
um
to
make me a better me
um
yeah
you got a lot of life ahead of you i i
have a lot of life ahead of me
and a lot of the time i forget that i
have a lot of life ahead of me yeah 14
you're just a baby i'm just a little bit
um
i forget
because i've been through a lot
i've been i've been through a lot i've
had
i've had a dad who hasn't known how to
handle parenting so he's just
left the building emotionally
um so it's so it's all up to my mom
i've had these these struggles of being
a kid who's unsupervised on the internet
therefore having a lot of people take
advantage of me i've had
just general teenager [ __ ]
um that's like
drama with my friends and stuff like
that but i've i've taken that to heart a
lot
and
i'm a lover boy what can i say i take a
lot of things to heart and it's
it's made me really depressed it's made
me go into really dark places
um
i've dealt with
um
i've dealt with a suicide attempt before
fun fact
it's not fun it's not fun at all
um
i've i've dealt with that
i've dealt with
being sexually assaulted in broad
daylight i've dealt with
so much but you know what
i still have a lot of life ahead of me
and none of this should have happened
none of that should have happened
and i know that shouldn't happen
shouldn't have happened
and
that's why i forget that i'm supposed to
be a kid
but i am
and
all i can tell you is try not to relate
too much to that victim
thinking that you
bring up sometimes and try to relate
more to
me how much of a survivor and how
courageous you are
that will help you a lot in the long run
i've i have survived a lot of things
and sometimes it is difficult to get out
of that mentality we're like damn
there's so much [ __ ] there's so much
[ __ ] and you get overwhelmed by all that
[ __ ]
um
and you feel like a person that
isn't in control of themselves
but
at the end of the day i am in control of
myself
the decisions you make in the next 10
years
will have so so much importance in the
rest of your life
and just try to keep yourself in the
mind frame to make great decisions
from 14 to 24 you're going to make all
kinds of decisions that'll
shape the rest of your life
and i do like i do like to think like
even though i am el bebe i
am capable of making good decisions
because i'm a smart boy
i'd consider myself smart boy and that's
really
what i like about myself when it comes
down to it
you're amazing
thank you thank you percy
let's do this again in two years
thank you very much
you